as the title of the marvel cinematic
universe's third spider-man film been
hiding in plain sight
the astute folks at murphy's multiverse
have pointed out that multiple media
outlets have been using a specific title
for what everyone else is calling the
untitled spider-man 3.
that title is spider-man homesick that
alleged subtitle certainly fits with its
predecessors spider-man homecoming and
spider-man far from home
however there hasn't been any explicit
confirmation from marvel studios or sony
pictures that spider-man homesick is the
official title of the third tom holland
starring spidey movie
murphy's multiverse claims that the
pre-production crew in atlanta is using
spider-man homesick as the film's
official title but we were unable to
confirm this to be the case
however the site's reports that two
outlets maxim and esquire have been
referring to spider-man 3 as spider-man
homesick are completely true
given that two unrelated outlets are
both reporting it the info must have
come from somewhere
either from an inside source of marvel
or sony an anonymous spokesperson or
just a random rumor online unfortunately
in this case there's a strong chance
that this info won't pan out
for one thing fielding a marvel
blockbuster with the word sick in the
title probably won't sound like a good
idea to anyone for a very long time
considering the events of 2020
for another this isn't the first time
that the title of spider-man 3 has been
revealed but the previous leak came from
4chan
and was reported on by cosmic book news
and we got this covered
both of which have a spotty track record
when it comes to accurate reporting
the 4chan rumor claims that the film
will be called spider-man home run
yeah i'm going to call that a foul oh
that's baseball right while it's also a
totally unconfirmed title originating
from an uncorroborated internet rumor
spider-man home run sounds like a more
plausible title than spider-man homesick
particularly considering the events of
spider-man far from home
that film concluded with peter parker
being publicly outed as spider-man and
framed for the murder of mysterio
through the use of a doctored video
spider-man's name is peter parker
[Music]
after that twist spidey seemed poised to
go on the run in the upcoming third
movie and that's not all
according to the 4chan rumor the film's
villain will be craven the hunter who
will presumably be tasked with tracking
the fugitive spider-man down
of course ahead of any official
announcement we'll probably get a better
idea of what spider-man 3's title will
really be
as soon as sony starts registering
domain names for the film's eventual
website
that process doesn't appear to have
begun yet but this is how fans were able
to sniff out the title of tom holland's
first solo flick almost a year before
its release
with several potential titles for
spider-man 3 now floating around in the
public sphere
it's prudent to ask whether tom holland
has spilled the beans on the real title
yet
the 24 year old star has never come
across a pertinent detail he couldn't
accidentally spoil
unfortunately for fans holland has
seemingly learned his lesson about
spoilers
so far he hasn't babbled on the title of
the third spider-man movie
in fact holland has been given only
enough clearance to offer up a few
decidedly non-spoilery details about the
film
first the actor disclosed in an
interview with the inquirer in march
2020 that zendaya who portrayed mj in
the first two movies will be back for
the third franchise installment he also
promised
that the story is totally insane but
kept a lid on any additional information
second holland revealed in july 2020
that spider-man 3 is expected to rap
shooting in february 2021
he first has to finish work on the video
game movie uncharted which has
reportedly resumed shooting in germany
after an extended pause due to the covet
19 pandemic
but that's all folks holland seems to be
keeping his usually loose lips shut this
time around
and since fellow spoiler master mark
ruffalo isn't in spider-man 3
he won't be of any help in accidentally
dropping details about the film either
the still untitled spider-man 3 is
currently slated for release in 2021 but
the actual date keeps bouncing around
we can safely say it'll be late 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you